and the Oscar goes to Barry Jenkins and
Terell Alvin mccraine from
Moonlight um you know I tell my students
that I teach sometimes be in love with
the process not the result but I would
really wanted this result because a
bajillion people are watching and all
you people out there who who feel like
there's no mirror for you that your life
is not reflected the academy has your
back the ACL you has your back we have
your back and for the next four years we
will not leave you alone we will not
forget you Amen brother I just want to
Echo everything you just said and all
those things but I also want to say
thank God for my mother who proved Pro
to me through her struggles and the
struggles that Naomi Harris portrayed
for all of you that we can really be
here and be somebody two boys from
Liberty City up here on this stage
representing 305 this goes out to all
those black and brown boys and girls and
non-gender conforming who don't see
themselves we're trying to show you you
and us so thank you thank you this is
for
you